IRL will be live in Miami with Patrick
Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt Gates and
Luke rowski join us there get your
tickets by clicking the link in the
description below or by going to
timcast.net
from Elon Musk I didn't call a tweet
call it a Twix Twix a post Twix look at
this I love that this is the uh look how
silly this looks this is ridiculous Elon
Musk went to Eagle Pass and started live
streaming at the border during the
immigration crisis I'm glad he's doing
it I'm glad he's making this a major
issue Elon going there makes this bigger
news for everyone it's fantastic but
this picture is just so silly look at
he's got like the guy behind him all
smileing and you know whatever it's
funny but he did two live streams and
this one you can actually see their
illegal immigrants that are behind this
I don't know orange chicken wire or some
sort and then we have this from The
Daily Mail Elon Musk reveals he backs
the border wall and says migrants must
have a shred of evidence to claim for
Asylum days after announcing visit to
crisis hit Eagle Pass so so look man
right now at Eagle Pass they're just
people are just flowing in there's
there's CBP allowing them in and then
they're all being shipped up to various
cities where we end up with mass
protests the scariest thing I I want to
make sure everybody understands because
I'm seeing these leftists on Twitter be
like who cares okay well the people in
Staten Island are the ones who are
getting all of these people dumped in
their neighborhoods and now the police
are beating and arresting the locals so
yeah it it matters and uh Elon Musk
parachuting in is good cuz it highlights
the problem yeah and elon's done a
really good job um lately of paying
attention to this issue months ago we
were covering the fact that he was you
know doing his exclamation point tweet
you know response to people which you
know uh it's not him saying anything
he's just calling attention to it with
this massive massive uh magnifying glass
that he has and he's been indicating
that more and more this is concerning
him and so the fact that he's going down
there right now is so important because
of course we see so many of our elected
officials in in a high-powered you know
uh right up all the way through the
presidency they they just can't even be
bothered bothered with the whole thing
and uh in the past month uh Eagle Pass
is averaging around 2,000 illegal
Crossings per day that's a lot and
that's one location right one location
it has been The Hot Spot pretty much for
the entire Biden border crisis um but uh
recently it's gotten even worse it was
bad every day all day but recently we
hit a a day record a single day record
which was about 2200 and two days later
it was 4,000 and so it's it's getting
worse and worse I've heard that because
of the because of you know South America
has the summer in our winter that the
springtime come March and April is going
to be when it it tends to bump up the
most and if we're getting you know 2,000
people a day or 3,000 people a day at at
one of the high volume border crossings
come March it's going to be insane
without some kind of change in policy
just in time for the election I mean I
don't want I think Biden would be doing
everything in his power right now to put
a stop to this because it's just in time
for the election I don't know that's why
I'm like do they want to lose running
Joe Biden and a border crisis because
immigration is a huge issue when you
have people in New York City protesting
AOC over immigration y'all Democrats are
in trouble yeah they're screaming at the
buses they're like yelling at everybody
telling them to go home New York City
actually today I saw a flyer that they
put out that's from the from the city of
New York saying go somewhere else you're
not going to be housed here this is a
very expensive city you will be better
off somewhere else the city is doing
that Democrats and this comes of course
only a couple weeks after Eric Adams
said they're destroying the city which
they are I me it's turning into a
nightmare yeah absolutely and you're
watching these liberals that have been
you know crowing about the city being a
sanctuary City and across the country
they' been doing this well they're
getting a taste of their own medicine
I'll be perfectly honest I wasn't a fan
of the busing stunt that Texas launched
last year I thought it was BAS basically
just them participating in the
redistribution of illegals and and we
know for a fact that the the amount that
are in New York City for instance it's
only about 10% were bust there by Texas
the other 90% are coming in uh of their
own accord being brought in by NOS being
brought in by the abide Administration
maybe even flying in we're learning now
straight to JFK so um it's only about
10% but it's been quite effective and it
has really highlighted the hypocrisy the
the the defense of the of the you know
busing the people from the border to
Texas was well he can't Deport them
anyway and I'm just like my attitude is
kind of look man if you have to choose
between sending a bus to New York and
just returning them to Mexico in
violation of I don't know federal law or
whatever i' I'd go with like hey man
they entered illegally we won't we won't
we're not we're going to send them right
back and then let let Mexico send uh
communication over how we deal with this
but if these people have already
illegally entered Mexico or they are
Mexican citizens then I don't see what
the argument is for some kind of like I
I I don't even think it's a law I think
it's some kind of treaty or something or
like international relations must be
held by the federal government and so
what happens as they come in and Texas
is like well we can't do anything the
federal government won't let us so they
put him on a bus and they send him to
New York I I like some of it right it it
it created a shock to the system it
created press but I think you're right
if if they didn't do this at all imagine
if Texas Florida and you know whatever
Arizona whichever other states were
doing it never did mhm they'd still have
a migrant crisis in New York City they'd
still be saying the same things only now
they have a scapegoat now they can say
it's Republicans that are doing it on
purpose right that's interesting and
then you also had DeSantis sending
people to Martha's Vineyard which was
sort of an amazing stunt I thought yeah
that was that was brilliant that was
good that was very CL sending a small
handful of people to a sanctuary city
that has the means to support them I
think was better for the people the the
migrants themselves got one of the best
deals ever you're going to Martha's
Vineyard baby I've never even been there
and then it made the people at the view
and all these other liberals lose their
minds and panic the the more you can
make people that have the luxury opinion
of open borders the more you can make
them feel the repercussions from that
the better right like because it's real
easy when you live in you know the
Northeast I'm from New Hampshire you
know Massachusetts it's easy to say oh
you should let people and they everyone
should be able to come in ETC um because
you don't feel the daily pressures that
you know that number of people
constantly straining your infrastructure
they don't feel it so if you can get
them
to partake in the actual you know the
actual reality ofing yeah I mean fair
enough I was trying to be a little a
little more uh a little more specific
with my words but uh but yeah
essentially if you can make them feel
the pain then that's a good thing
because until most people have that
luxury have luxury opinions that don't
they don't they don't affect them so
they're like well it's okay for this
because someone else will deal with it
it's very very easy to say it's someone
else's problem it's really hard to say
it's someone else's problem when you
can't walk out of your door without
stepping in human feces you know right
New York already had that problem San
Francisco I mean my attitude is kind of
uh at this point everybody should be uh
as self-sufficient as possible they
should be doing what they can to get out
of cities to get more I mean look it's
just you're better off we've got the we
got we have we have a video that we'll
talk about for in the members only
section tonight where it's uh students
fighting at high school is a trans
student fighting beating up uh but we we
we'll we'll save that but my point is
not to Hash that story out before we get
to it these things are happening in your
schools in these in these districts
where they've got these this weird
wokeness ideology you need to get away
from these places you need to be you
need to be self-sufficient
self-sustainable because it's clear the
government does not have your back
Staten Island is the perfect example of
social order breakdown Philadelphia is
the next best example they bring in
illegal immigrants into Staten Island
when the locals say hey man you can't do
this is our neighborhood the cops beat
and arrest them and then you get
Philadelphia where people run around 100
people running around smash teenagers
smashing up storefronts and stealing
iPhones iPads fighting with cops getting
and and only half of them get arrested
social order breakdown it's happening
does it completely break down till it
doesn't exist I don't know but ain't
nobody coming to save you even if Trump
gets arrested you got to still deal with
the on the ground stuff happening in
front your house what what did I say you
said arrested oh no no elected he
already got arrested right he already
got arrested if Donald Trump gets
elected
he's it's it's it's it's going to help I
hope I believe there is a strong
probability that gets things back on
track but it still means the swamp is
all around you you may hope that Trump
pulls that plug and drains a lot of it
but it's going to be there for a while
you don't clean up this mess overnight
so that being said The more I see this
stuff the more I'm hoping that people
become self-sufficient and remove
yourself from the ramifications of the
horrible policy so if you're not in New
York City you're going like wow that's
that's too bad for the people who live
there who voting who are voting for this
it does suck for the people who are
there who don't want it but at a certain
point I'm kind of thinking like the only
way this is resolved is is is getting
resolved or will be resolved is because
people in New York City are now
experiencing the problem when it was
just a Texas problem they said who cares
you're crazy now that it's a New York
problem now you're going to get the
whole country screaming about illegal
immigration finally and you had recently
a video of Chicago residents who most of
them were presumably Democrats raing the
city council and saying and in you know
essentially paraphrasing what they said
but almost a direct quote if you don't
do something about this we're going to
do something about this and you're not
going to like what we do that's crazy
that's scary man we don't none of that
yeah and there's a there's a lot of
black Democrats in Chicago who are
really fed up with this too I thought
that was really interesting too for a
minute I kind of had this hope that
perhaps there would be an abolition of
color lines and we could all just be
like we're Americans you guys are invad
I'm sorry that your country is going to
going to hell over there but uh we don't
want ours to have that happen to it I
said this yesterday I really need to say
it again because I because not look for
people who watch every show you hear me
say some things a couple times maybe a
lot but not everybody watches every show
imagine what it must be like and I I can
only imagine I'm not black right but
imagine you're a Democrat black or white
The Narrative is black people have been
oppressed by this country and are owed
for it reparations should be paid now
imagine you are a black voter and many
of you watching probably are and you're
being told over and over again how much
you're owed from the because of what
this country has done to you then they
say but don't worry we're not going to
give you money every four years we'll
dangle the carrot in front of your face
we're going to claim we owe you the
money then we're going to open the
Border bring in people who don't even
live here who've not experienced
anything we've claimed you've
experienced and then we're going to give
them money it's it's it's it's at that
point you know my attitude is kind of
like if you don't give me money I'm not
going to cry about it just don't take my
tax dollar
but if you dangle the money in front of
me saying like yeah this is your money
you know we don't worry we're going to
get it to you oh who's that guy here you
go buddy you you toss him a chunk of
cash now I'm pissed off well that was
the thing too in New York is they were
bringing in illegal immigrants setting
up a whole tent city type of things
giving them free Xboxes and stuff moving
homeless New Yorkers out of shelters I
mean there was already there were
already plenty of homeless in New York
New Yorkers families people with jobs
who can't afford to live there but they
have a job their families are they're
like trying to make it work and these
people these New Yorkers were moved out
of the shelters that were built for New
Yorkers um so that illegal immigrants
could come in all because of stupid Joe
Biden and the thing too about that is
the you know the situation in New York
where there was a sanctuary City and
also where there's a right to shelter
law which means that if someone shows up
and ask for a place to sleep the laws
you have to give it to them that only
works if you're dealing with the you
know know the homeless residents of your
own City it doesn't work when you're
dealing with 100,000 people from
wherever who also are not assimilated
they don't want to assimilate and we
have Progressive saying you shouldn't
assimilate you know so there was a case
today someone was an illegal immigrant
was arrested for allegedly um raping a
seven-year-old girl in an airport hotel
God you have the Roosevelt Hotel we had
a reporter go out for human events
Jackie toov and she was saying that the
hotel is essentially cultural divided
it's like um Hispanics on one side and
Africans on on another and there's
fights on the corner you know I mean
what a mess when you had immigrants
coming through Ellis Island the idea was
they were going to assimilate their kids
were American and you and they could be
they could be adequately placed yes so
we know hey your new family's coming in
we got we have we have locations in this
area where we can help you get set up
and that way people integrate into the
society when people come here illegally
they they just go and they find out
where their friends are and they create
enclaves I don't blame them for doing
it's what humans do but then you end up
with what what isolated many societies
right like neighborhoods that don't view
themselves as part of the greater uh uh
City or or state or whatever and then no
go zones if that allowed to proliferate
proliferate even further but you know I
had a lot of relatives that came in my
family tree and um that came through New
York City they immigrated there and when
they were coming through you had to
provide chest x-rays right you had to
provide a sponsor that was already in
the you have five bucks you or something
you had to maybe like I think you had to
have some amount of cash but you also
couldn't have a job already lined up
right because the deal was you couldn't
be taking a job from an American already
here exct and now you have AOC and hakee
Je Jeff and all of these people coming
out being like we have to make sure they
can get jobs people in New York need
jobs New Yorkers need jobs like Jack
Jack Fresco made a great point that I
brought up earlier today he uh he was in
an interviews the Ze guy Z old Z
Zeitgeist stuff if you guys are familiar
with that documentary he said when he
was a kid during the Depression he saw
people in an unemployment line and
across the street was a factory with no
workers and he was like why can't we get
the workers and the unemployment line
into the factory well he wasn't
literally saying you could he was saying
like this is an issue of a failed
economic State the workers from the
unemployment line couldn't necessarily
do the job at the factory so you have
people who need work and place that
needs workers and it can't make it work
but from understanding that principle if
you've got
let's just flat numbers 100 jobs in your
town and you've got 110 people okay
you've got 10 people who need jobs some
people die some people move out now
there's a few job openings 50 illegal
immigrants come in no let's say 10 let's
say just 10 right
10% they start taking up these jobs and
the left argues that the immigrants
create demand and create jobs yes but
not immediately so what happens is these
jobs are going to be filled based on
Market competition some of these
businesses are going to say well we're
going to hire these guys more
importantly AOC is saying they're going
to get work permits for these
non-citizens which means if you're
someone struggling to find work AOC is
going to make sure one of these guys
takes the jobs that are available that
you should be getting exactly and then
maybe maybe in a year or two the demand
will increase enough to where more jobs
will will come into fruition but ain't
nobody's creating a job at their
business based off of a week a month or
a couple months exactly if Revenue
increases like let's say like 100
illegal immigrants come into my
neighborhood and now I'm selling more
cheeseburgers yes at the end of the
month I'll calculate how much money I
made how much how many more Burgers I
got to buy what my profits were and then
we'll carry on maybe after six months
I'll say okay you know demand is getting
is getting greater and greater we're
going to bring out some more employees
but it's not going to be right away
right no it's not going to be right away
and how much when they when that happens
how much of what they're earning then
gets sent back home we have REM
remittances never get talked about and
how much are they going to start taking
out of the system because inevitably
uh they find ways to leech the system
you know uh whether it's you know
through the schools or through you know
welfare or food Sams EBT programs and
then another example of just the madness
in New York City and um residents
American citizens being pushed to the
back of the line we had at the beginning
of the school year something like 19,000
illegal alien children entered the
school system and so kids were showing
up to school and at city schools and
American citizens were being turned away
from school and we're told very often
that a lot of these kids the only meals
they're getting that day are at school
we're told that all the time they tell
us that all the time and then you had
Leticia James the Attorney General of
New York who's trying to destroy Trump's
life and his business and his entire
family she said that uh New York state
was going to sue school districts that
did not allow the children of illegal
immigrants into the schools now the
thing in New York is New York City
Schools got shut down like March 13th
20120 they were out that whole semester
they were out most of the entire next
year there were policies in place where
if your kid got exposed to coid then
they couldn't go to school for two weeks
and there was like some whole testing
regimen which we went through like a
half a dozen times my kid was never in
school it was a disaster so you have all
of these kids in New York a lot of whom
are poor already a lot of whom have
English as a second language who are
already behind they're behind in maths
they're behind in science and reading
and everything already behind now you're
throwing in a bunch of kids who have
made some like ridiculously difficult
Trek all through South America to get
here who are also behind they haven't
been in school and they also don't speak
English so what's going to happen to the
citizens the the citizen children of New
York they're supposed to inherit this
city they're supposed to like you know
keep the lights on keep it going all
night as you know as the the story of
New York goes um and they're not going
to have a chance and the state is going
to make sure they don't have a chance
that's their goal and not to mention on
the school thing the New York the school
officials admitted before the school
year started that if you were basically
a migrant child and you were entering
the school system you did not have to
provide proof of immunization the way
that Americans for anything and then
there's tuberculosis at the border right
what's going on that like why are we so
obsessed with destroying our own country
and destroying our own kids chance to
succeed you know and then telling
immigrants like you don't even have to
be American if the immigrants who are
coming in do not decide to American and
take up our cultural values which who
even knows what they are at this point
then the nation is screwed look what's
going on in France and Sweden and all of
these places thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 P.M and become a member over at
timcast.net